je reçois à présent pour la suite de ce
78 Christine CLIS bonsoir vous êtes la
présidente de l'association Var voisin
adulte relais vous organisez le 11
février à la Maison des associations à
voisin le bretonux une soirée
d'information la violence morale sachez
la détecté et bonsoir à Chantal
paulitexier vous êtes la présidente
d'agissz contre la violence association
basée sur morpa et vous interviendrez
lors de ce rendez-vous alors on va
précise déjà peut-être pour débuter
justement ce sujet que vous allez
aborder la violence morale comment on
définit la violence morale alors la
violence morale c'est un terme générique
que nous avons choisi pour regrouper ce
qui s'appelle la violence psychologique
le harcèlement la manipulation donc
comment définir la violence morale euh
bah c'est c'est une prise de pouvoir
c'est un acte de domination et de
contrôle sur autrui bon c'est une
définition super courte et très simple
là mais c'est très difficile de la
détecter justement là on est dans le
cœur du de la du rendez-vous qui sera
proposé c'est sachez la détecter à quel
moment on parle de vraiment de violence
morale au-delà d'une d'une d'une dispute
de mésentente au sein d'un couple par
exemple c'est quand il y a vraiment
cette fameuse prise de pouvoir quand il
y a emprise quand il y a quand il y a
une personne qui domine une autre qui la
contrôle qui met en place une violence
économique qui met en place bah du
harcèlement donc des des des
humiliations par exemple des insultes
répété il faut que les actes soient
réitérés
si on dit tout simplement tu es idiote
c'est pas proprement parlé un acte de
violence si c'est pas réitéré avec une
intention directe une intention derrière
de quotidien avec des privations
financières économiques qui les pression
dont vous parliez par exemple on garde
la carte bleue et on l'empêche le
conjoint de l'utiliser là on est
vraiment dans le cadre ça c'est des
signau concrets qui peuvent qui peuvent
alerter expliquez-nous pourquoi avoir
fait appel à cette association pour
organiser ce rendez-vous sur voisin le
Bretonneux parce que c'est pas
uniquement le travail que vous mener
avec l'association Var vous intervenez
sur un domaine beaucoup plus large oui
alors justement l'association Var met
toujours des des intervenants
spécialisés sur des thèmes différents
pour justement parler au public et les
les personnes concernés vont après voir
directement l'intervenant qu'est-ce qui
a motivé ce rendez-vous autour de de ce
thème spécifiquement mais c'est un
malheureusement c'est un thème qu'on
entend pas journellement mais presque et
à tous les niveaux alors là c'est
spécifique viol
morale intrafamiliale mais ça peut être
aussi bien au niveau scolaire au niveau
professionnel donc savoir détecter cette
violence ça peut être dans des propos
donc c'est tout le monde peut être
concerné malheureusement et c'est pour
ça que Madame pa elle ne sera pas la
seule intervenante une autre
intervenante muri ano qui sera également
présente conseillère sociojudiciaire et
qui interviendra elle est l'auteur d'un
ESS sur le stalking tout à fait
qu'est-ce que le stalking alors le
stalking c'est le terme anglo-saxon qui
désigne une forme de harcèlement euh par
intrusion la traque ça signifie la
traque hein c'est un terme de de la
chasse euh donc c'est c'est ça ça se
rapporte à tout ce qui est euh
harcèlement pur et du harcèlement
euh c'est c'est très difficile à évoquer
c'est très lié à l'érotomanie par
exemple mais c'est pas le fait que des
rotomanes on parle beaucoup de ces
comédiens ou de ces vedettes qui ont été
harcelé par délire amoureux ou par dépis
amoureux euh en tout cas par fixation
délirante mais ça se produit aussi dans
dans le couple des hommes qui ne
supportent pas de laisser partir leur
proie là je parle de prédateur pas autre
chose euh ne pas confondre avec ce qui
ce que certains appellent le harcèlement
amoureux non non stop c'est vraiment de
deux termes antinomiques hein ça ça n'a
strictement rien à voir donc le stocking
c'est ce que c'est ce que peuvent vivre
certaines femmes et certains hommes
après la séparation par exemple quand le
conjoint ne les lâche plus fait le pied
de grue devant chez eux les suit en
voiture intervient dans leur à leur
travail voilà c'est c'est ver qu'il y a
une loi aussi qui est passée je vais
vous demander tout à l'heure en quoi ça
va changer les choses en tout cas en
quoi ça ça les a changé on va
s'intéresser à ça dans un instant
auparavant dites-moi tout de même vous
n'avez pas peur que les victimes
justement que ce soit des femmes ou des
hommes craignent de venir J justement
participer à ce rendez-vous pour
échanger parce qu'il est difficile
justement ensuite d'extérioriser de
d'exprimer et justement de se rendre
compte qu'on est tout simplement victime
de harcèlement et qu'on n pas dans une
simple dispute alors au moment de la
conférence c'est anonyme les personnes
viennent on connaît pas leur nom on sait
pas du tout leur vie je POS cette
question pour rassurer éventuellement
les gens qui nous suiv qui voudrai venir
à voisin on connaî pas leur vie on
connait pas leur adresse ils viennent
ils sont anonymes ils rentrent ils
écoutent ils repartent on ne sait rien
de leur vie et on leur demande rien donc
c'est ouvert à toutes les personnes
intéressées et les personnes qui
auraient vraiment un cas personnel on
propose justement des cycles
c'est-à-dire trois soirées de 2h à une
semaine d'intérale avec Madame Paul txé
et Madame Murielle Antero pour justement
ces cas particuliers qui voudrai s'en
sortir et le rendez-vous donc pour
l'instant est prévu le 11 février si
vous voulez y assister autour des
violences morales j'en revient à cette
loi du 9 juillet 2010 date importante
une loi qui vise à pénaliser les
violences pologique et le harcèlement
estce que cette loi 2 ans après même 3
ans bientôt après a changé quelque chose
euh pas grand-chose non c'est une loi
qui est très difficile à appliquer alors
je fais un distingo quand
même le déli de harcèlement s'applique
peut-être un petit peu plus facilement
que le délit de violence psychologique
les procureurs préfèrent au délit de
violence psychologique continuer à
appliquer le délit de violence
volontaire avec intention de nuire bon
ce qui me paraît à mon sens assez normal
quelque part part maintenant le mérite
de ces deux articles de loi c'est
d'avoir nommé les
choses du coup ça devrait freiner un
temps soit peu les agresseurs c'est pas
vrai mais bon voilà il y a eu des
condamnations il y a des justement des
cas concrets qui ont été jugé avec cette
ce de pas eu du tout de condamnation au
niveau du délit de violence
psychologique ça c'est le rapport sur
l'application de la loi qui le dit c'est
pas moi a priori il y aurait eu des des
de harcèlement qui ont été qui ont été
suivis enfin où il y a eu des
condamnations le le le rapport n'en fait
pas mention mais nous on a eu des cas à
l'association donc on sait
qu'effectivement il y a eu vraiment des
délis des pardon des condamnations donc
des délis ceci dit condamnation les deux
ça ne sont pas antinomiques journée des
victimes juste profitez de votre
présence sur ce plateau c'est le 22
février journée européenne des victimes
vous allez y participer cette journée va
consister en quoi c'est justement pour
que les victimes s'expriment pas
uniquement de violence morale d'ailleurs
victimes c'est pas vraiment pour que les
victimes s'expriment c'est pour que les
associations qui luttent contre les
violences au sens large parce qu'il y a
pas que la violence morale ou la
violence conjugale il y a aussi
l'inceste il y a il y a vraiment toutes
les
associations qui qui lut contre la
contre la violence en règle générale il
y a aussi la police et la gendarmerie
qui sont présentes euh c'est une
association pour montrer qu'il existe
des ressources c'est surtout ça donc
elle s'adresse effectivement à tout
public aussi aux victimes qui si elles
veulent bien venir bon c'est c'est une
manifest organisé sur Paris 22 février
tout à fait alors je je saurais
malheureusement pas vous dire occasion
de le redire mais en tout cas vous y
participerez je profite de votre
présence pour pour le mentionner puis
cette toute dernière question vous étiez
déjà venu sur ce plateau à plusieurs
reprises mais la dernière fois c'était
pour nous faire part des difficultés
financières d'agisser contre les
violences aujourd'hui la situation va
mieux euh alors disons qu'on a bouclé
notre budget 2012 et que on mettra pas
la clé sous la porte en mars comme
c'était prévu initialement mais la
situation reste très très difficile
parce que bah chaque année les
financements baissent alors que les
dépenses augmentent voilà c'est un
calcul très basique he et qu'il y a
toujours un découvert et que doncah
l'association elle est sans s un danger
donc si des donateurs éventuels nous
écoutent par contre il y a une nouveauté
par rapport à septre quand je suis venu
c'est que nous sommes euh d'intérêt
général donc nous pouvons délivrer des
reçus fiscaux pour tous les dons voilà
ça c'est quand même donc si vous
souhaitez aider justement cette
association agissez tous les
renseignements qui sont affichés puis
vous pourrez bien évidemment rencontrer
la présidente lors de la journée la
soirée du 11 février 20h30 cette
discussion à voisin le Bretonneux autour
de la violence morale comment la
détecter merci à toutes les deux d'être
venu pour parler de ce rendez-vous nous
sommes le mercredi et le mercredi c'est
le jour de la culture sur TVfil la
chronique culture tout de
suite